this year bushlight is coming back to
the super bowl with an ad where they
resurrect an old jingle that they had
that first debuted in 1979 called head
for the mountains
it's been a few years since bush had an
ad in the super bowl they had one a few
years ago where opening the can sound
like a river roaring you know to talk
about it being crisp but this year
they're focusing on a certain line from
the original song where they talk about
the smoothness of bush so the commercial
starts with two friends that are in the
woods and they sit down for for a beer
and one of them says you know whenever
you crack open a bush light the mountain
starts singing
all of a sudden giant people appear over
the mountain and they start singing the
old song
after a few seconds one of them says hit
it giant kennedy
[Music]
leaning into the kenny g aspect of that
obviously well known for his smooth jazz
over the last several decades so smooth
tell us how did you get involved with
with bushlight for this uh campaign
well i'm not sure who called whom but i
did get the request and i knew the song
a little bit but i also knew it more
than normal because when i was doing one
of my cameos one of the requests was for
me to play the song this old song head
for the mountains from the late 70s
and i thought okay cool so i learned it
and so when they asked me do you want to
be part of this i said well yeah i know
the melody already so it's going to be
great i also talked to daniel blake who
is one of the marketers at
anheuser-busch
about the ad and he talked about why
kennedy is a good fit for them and and
what they're trying to get across busch
light and kenny g a little bit
unexpected but he was the perfect person
he was the perfect person to refresh the
song there's one key lyric in the song
uh it's it's cold and it's smooth and
it's waiting for you obviously talking
about bushlight beer but when we heard
this line and we're really analyzing the
song we're like man no one no one in
music is smoother
than kenny g once i came up with my
parts and recorded them i wanted to have
everything completely done before we
shot so that i could lip sync i'd call
it lip sync finger sync basically the
part now i think i'm the only one that
cared about that but i do care about it
because as a saxophone player i want to
look at myself and know that when i'm
doing that those are the notes kenny g
you know over the years has become
ubiquitous in a lot of ways he's been
the butt of some jokes but he's also in
other ways really embrace them if i'm
the butt of the joke if it's funny i
love it it doesn't bother me because
it's truly funny for example
in south park i'm the guy that plays a
note that makes everyone you know crap
their pants
i mean that's funny i like that kind of
stuff so to be the butt of the joke if
you get the joke you can enjoy it
and if you don't get the joke i think
you're you're letting your ego get in
the way because you know
the life that we have that
where people are you know supporting you
and wanting you to to go around the
world and play for them and it seems a
shame to me when i see the arts some of
the artists that
maybe take that for granted and and
don't want any you know funny
ribs i don't mind that at all i've
always enjoyed it
[Music]